I'm joined today by Omer MOA who is a
professor of economics at the University
of Warwick and also in the
interdisciplinary center Israel it's so
great to speak to you today you know
we've been talking about two different
but related issues for many years now
one is that of wealth and income
inequality in the world within specific
countries however you want to sort of
slice it and we've also been talking
about the development of technology
including automation artificial
intelligence robotics etc we have to
think about over time looking into the
future what impact will the development
of new technology have on wealth
inequality and income inequality and I
don't think it will come as a surprise
to many in our audience that that we are
getting to a point where technology will
actually grow inequality to talk to us
generally about why that is and how that
works well okay I mean it's that the
facts are that income inequality has
significantly increase in most developed
countries in the last I would say four
decades more or less and I think the
consensus among researchers is that it
is because of technology and then you
could think of different mechanisms I
will say the main thing is that you
still need a very skilled to implement
the new technology to develop the new
technology you still need the unskilled
and to do some even simple tasks that
the robot robots and machines cannot
replace sometimes the most simple work
of that waiting or cleaning and the
tender is the middle class and a lot of
say jobs that were that ended because
technology replaced these jobs and I
think the more recent trend is that
there is some kind of a shrink of the
middle class because of these phenomena
well when you look at reports which say
and there's a variety of these reports
but many of them will sort of estimate
the percentage of current jobs that
are maybe automatable at some point in
the future and they will usually give
you a breakdown of the industries within
which those jobs exist when you look at
sort of the education level required for
many of those jobs it's easy to see how
the the jobs that are less likely to be
automatable by and large sort of holding
other factors equal our jobs that
require more education so that seems to
me Oh more like a very direct way in
which if you start to see technology
favor maintaining jobs that require more
education that could become quite a
self-fulfilling process which will
increase inequality drastically
absolutely I agree I would just add
maybe a distinction that is important to
make between the level of technology so
you have the new technology that
replaces an unskilled or a less skilled
worker so sometimes it could also be a
skilled worker some of the technology
today replaces a lot of they work the
doctors to medical doctors but let's say
but by and large this is not the group
that is mostly effective the dental is
the rate of change except because a lot
of technologies when they're first
introduced they require a skilled worker
to implement to work with but over the
time think of word processors that say
stuff like that the new technology
becomes very friendly and less skilled
workers could implement could use it so
what happens is that the rate of change
the the fact that we all the time are
exposed to more to new a new stuff
arriving you need the skilled workers
the high ability workers at this end of
implementing the new technology until it
becomes a more friendly to the less
skilled workers and I think that's a
major source of deriving inequality well
along those lines could we it is it
reasonable to think that
there could be a technological
advancement that simultaneously
increases our our total level of
inequality but also increases welfare
for most if not all people in other
words is it possible that we might be
able to raise the standard of living for
everybody to some degree however we
might also increase inequality as a
result of that technology at the same
time absolutely I think that this is
what happens in a flock most of the last
a decade it varies between countries so
if you think of the United States there
was a slowdown it's not even there
reduction in wage earnings or in the
lower part of the distribution but most
developed countries this is not the case
Mike my home country Israel for instance
inequality has increased but the the
welfare of the lower-income earners the
less skilled workers has also increased
now there is a bit of a philosophical
question here is about how do you
measure welfare because if you think
we're welfare is of course the bundle of
consumption I could afford and having
all these innovation increased the wages
of even the less skilled workers and
increase the variety of consumption good
is that the technology we use is also
part of our consumption the smartphone's
we have helped us a lot in anything we
could waste time on Facebook and stuff
like that and enjoy so that's one side
of it but then there is the inequality
and if my welfare or one welfare is
negatively affected by Envy by
understanding that other people income
growth is much faster then you could
easily get the result in which the
welfare of the lower tail in the income
distribution actually goes down this is
sort of difficult to measure in a sort
of net in
for economists isn't it I mean imagine
for example some significant medical
technology that eliminates or eradicate
I don't know some disease that affects
people regardless of income so that's a
really good thing for welfare but at the
same time some people are enriched by
that and inequality in cities becomes
more noticeable and we know that that
connects to more petty crime on the
street right how could we even get a
sense of sort of the net impact of that
I think it's very hard to get the sense
of the net the impact of course you
could measure a crime and you could
measure the effect of crime on people
it's not easy but the one thing that is
almost is very hard perhaps impossible
to measure is really this envious sex
that the vicious misery people have from
inequality per se that does indeed not
something easy to measure but still if
you know even things that we cannot
measure we should be aware that they
exist I want to ask a question that
maybe is more philosophical than
economic or at least maybe relates more
to the philosophy of economics than
something that we can measure are there
ever good reasons to try to artificially
restrict the advancement of technology
and we often have this example of you
know when when we had horse buggy
drivers and the idea of the car was
presented there were those concerned
about the jobs that would be lost with
the advent of automobiles for those who
drive the horse buggies and of course
now it would seem absurd to have
prevented the advent of the automobile
to save those jobs but it's an
interesting thought experiment
nonetheless how do you think about as
someone in the field the artificial
restriction of technological advancement
yeah I think that's a fantastic point
obviously I would say that like any
other economies as far as I understand
we would really object having like
government committee that would decide
which technologies are allowed and which
are not not based on health or risk but
based on their effect on inequality and
their effects on the eliminating jobs
that would be extremely risky and indeed
in the short run people tend to object
some technological innovations that
destroy jobs and politicians would
definitely go with them if they could
and how do I know all that because there
is something a parallel between
innovations that destroy jobs but
nevertheless increase welfare and by the
way should always emphasize that is by
destroying jobs new jobs are created we
didn't move over the last two hundred
years in the nudist has broke great
machines prevent their machinery to
replace workers that the fear of
increasing unemployment still didn't
happen I mean I don't know what will
happen in the future but so far every
day every year there is someone saying
look soon technology would destroy jobs
and unemployment would go up so far it
didn't happen but here's the parallel we
have which is import you open an
economic to imports of goods it's also
destroys jobs because instead of
producing a good you buy for a lower
price these create it cleans the jobs in
this economy so you could think of the
car industry in the US for instance you
buy cheaper cars from Japan or Korea and
it destroys part of the jobs in the US
and it's exactly like a technological
innovation because by large it increases
the welfare of the population people
could buy cheaper cars or better cars
and in fact unemployment doesn't go up
so that's another interesting fact
because just like technological
innovations some jobs are created some
jobs are
a destroy summer created or the same
thing with imports you import more jobs
are destroyed but as a result of
importing there is a simple economic
mechanism that increases exports a new
jobs are created and you could stream
the unlike technology politicians in
many cases try to block imports what is
the difference
interesting very very interesting we've
been speaking with Omer mala professor
of economics at the University of
Warwick and the interdisciplinary center
Israel thanks so much for talking to me
about this today thank you very much